I don't like racism at all it bothers me
after a controversial season Lee Garrett
sat in the hot seat on The Bachelorette
men tell all reunion special
we spoke to Bachelorette Rachel Lindsay
and leaves fellow contestants after the
specials taping I'm sorry for saying
things when I was not educated and
ignorant and those subjects you think
Lee's apology was real no to be honest
with you it was a big sign what should
we do from here these should go educate
himself about different cultures women
gay rights like there's so much more to
learn did you believe his apology I mean
yes I if you're gonna apologize if
you're gonna fix your mouth and your
lips to apologize to me I'm going to
accept it and I'm not going to question
it do you believe his apology was
legitimate no I don't I really don't I
think that's all he was trying to do
tonight was manipulate the audience and
Chris Harrison knew whoever else what
was his name
I honestly did not believe Ali's apology
tonight I feel like he just felt the
pressure for so many people he tries to
do a good job acting remorseful but I
don't really think it was very authentic
a lot of times people don't experience
remorse until their their backs are
against the wall so you know what I felt
like leans back was against the wall
tonight you know I was a good person I
love that the guys were responding
without anger and more of support and
trying to educate Lee I think it was a
good step for him tonight and hopefully
education helps a lot and I think these
guys were very helpful you said that you
do not believe that the show did not
know about least
can you explain that you stand by that I
know that all of us after you go through
a very thorough social media scrubbing
this is very hard for me to believe they
didn't know about lis social media that
being said I don't believe it that you
know they they were Tassili in a
malicious intent
[Music]